I use works of art to teach everybody
from Everyday People to those for whom
looking is the job like Navy Seals and
homicide detectives and Trauma nurses
the fact is that no matter how skilled
you might be at looking you still have
so much to learn about seeing
so interesting I want to keep watching
that that is New York Times best-selling
author lawyer and art historian Amy
Herman she teaches people that looking
at art can sharpen their brains Herman
has work as you just heard her say with
Senators with Navy Seals the FBI and top
CEOs to improve their critical thinking
skills and doing so using art now she's
adapted her 2016 book visual
intelligence for kids and teens smart
use your eyes to boost your brain is
published by Simon Schuster which like
CBS is part of Paramount Global and Amy
joins us now Amy thank you very much for
being here thanks for having me I think
the first question that people will have
if all the ways you can improve critical
thinking why use art
one of the reasons we love to use art to
teach people is because everybody sees
something
everybody sees something and people
don't think of art as anything beyond
being on a museum wall but we can
actually use the power of Art and human
creativity to solve problems help people
fix things and there's no language
barrier art speaks to everybody
regardless of what language you speak
you gave a lot of examples in your book
and I'm just happy to say or embarrassed
to tell you I failed nearly every one of
them only got one right out of the whole
book because I started playing the game
myself and I pulled what I thought was
interesting because you said look at
this set of splotches or blocks you
called it and when you look at it what
do you see can you put that up John
because I studied this very very hard so
Nate what do you see Tony what do you
see when you just said first class black
and white black and white I kind of see
like a mouse peering down on some sort
of a wreck a mouse peering down well
what you're really seeing there is a
cow's face yeah now now that I can see
it very very clearly wow yeah but I
studied it I went back and forth and I
said what is this here to teach me how
does being able to identify things
because you're you focus on visual
intelligence right that's your whole
thing you want us to be visually
intelligent right why is that important
visual intelligence means seeing what
other people don't don't see and also
gaining Clarity from multiple
perspectives understanding that no two
people see anything the same way you're
wearing a red dress right we can all
agree that you're wearing a red dress
but the red that each of us sees is very
different so the first time I
encountered that cow exercise I did the
same thing you did it looks like a bunch
of splotches what am I looking at and
the person sitting next to me said how
can you not see the cow in that picture
and I said cow and then they outlined it
and I thought if I'm not seeing this
what else am I missing and the fact that
she saw it immediately and I saw nothing
kind of scared me yeah me too but what
should we learn from this Amy because
you said it can help you be better
parents you've helped homicide
detectives you have helped Radiologists
I thought that was interesting because
you help everybody to see things
differently it would help to divide in
this country yeah see like I see it yeah
yeah absolutely and just going into a
situation for kids on the playground
parents going into a conference knowing
in the boardroom in the courtroom in the
operating room nobody's seeing things
the way you do so how do we fix that
yeah be able to communicate more
effectively what it is that we're seeing
instead of saying you are so wrong or
how can you say that tell them what you
see
ask them what they see and that's how
you hone your visual intelligence well
because you say people think you see
with your eyes not your brain but really
both of them have to work to you or or
are working together you say they are
working together people don't realize
that the retina which is you know you
learn in third grade that's the thing in
the back of the eye that flips your
images upside down the redness part of
the brain not part of the eye yeah and
so by the time you're flipping images
you're already thinking about them and
thinking about assumptions and
associations and experiences and again
no two people see anything the same way
no two people observe yeah and that's
why we have to communicate more
effectively as you said even in Congress
yeah you're right about that so you're
saying that we need to ask better
questions about what we see what do you
mean by that when we think about how we
formulate our questions look you ask
people questions all the time right
right but you have to think about what
you want to say and what you don't want
to say and you have to think about
framing your question to elicit exactly
the information that you need for your
purpose because one thing we can all
agree on nobody has time to waste right
and something else I've learned is how
you look at something is fundamental to
what you see so if you've had a bad
morning the dog is thrown up you know
you're in a bad mood that's going to
affect how you see things and just
knowing that
I'm looking forward to giving this book
to my teenager uh Katie Herman thank you
very much for being here really
appreciate it smart is on sale wherever
you like to buy your books I like the
title